what does this night mean to you it's
been wonderful to just be recognized
especially along with my cast I'm so
happy that the show was recognized in
this way it's just an honor the show was
the most nominated show so is it still
that much of a shock surprise when you
hear your name you hear the show's name
I don't know why but it still is I mean
we just got here so it's
Tyler like I've really brought tears to
my I never know what's going to bring a
tear to my eye and Tyler that really got
me see Eddie Murphy give him a standing
ovation yeah they're excited for him I
was I mean I don't know it just was
heartwarming to see him win that you
have a 4 30 a.m call time correct oh my
God no I'm 6 18. oh oh the boss comes in
late the boss can come when she wants
who said that well that's what a couple
of years yeah she has that because
you gave her that call
he's Mercedes yeah
how will you guys celebrate tonight I
think we're just gonna have a little fun
at the after party and then probably go
home because we have these early ass
call times
production set not me I was gonna say
what
bring you a little I know you like to
dance because we've seen it I do like to
dance but you know what today I think my
dress is too big to dance and I'm tired
and I'm honestly just I'm happy that we
get to have this moment together so I'm
excited to do that I may not dance a lot
or drink a lot but I'm gonna have a good
time to show the way it has changed the
way the people view teachers you know we
haven't had a show like this that really
highlighted Public School teachers since
welcome back Carter if you want to go
all the way back what does that mean for
the for all the teachers now that are
benefiting from what you've done I'm
happy me that that is the case I mean I
would like to see more I've said every
interview I want teachers to be paid
more that is my ultimate goal I think
not with the show just in general now
let's make over the show is to make
people laugh but I just think teachers
should be paid more I hope Abbott can
Aid in that just seeing what it is they
do I know it's a comedy and we make
people laugh but there was episodes like
the one that we just had their episode
last week about
um Lee Sam Walter's character Melissa
helping a child you know with reading
that that's important our teachers are
our first steps into life and so
um I just want people to appreciate what
they do what do you think the Philly
icon thinks about this the Philly icon
yes gritty I think gritty is so happy I
think he's home Kicking and Screaming I
think he wishes he was here tonight we
would have invited him if we could have
but he is a mascot not a real person
what how do you keep all this in I mean
you have so much going on
um I I just I don't know I love being
able to focus on Abbott I do it's like
and to have something I care about so
much and zero in on it it's easy to
focus on and I love it I love it it
doesn't feel hard to focus on it because
I love every aspect of this job
congratulations thank you guys thank you
so much
thank you